Buongiorno a tutti Io nella mia
conferenza Voglio cercare di attirare
l'attenzione di favorire una riflessione
su sul lavoro ma sul lavoro diciamo
contestualizzato nella globalizzazione
perché ne parliamo molto magari a
livello locale a livello nazionale
quando va bene e si presta molto meno
attenzione al fatto che spesso il lavoro
subisce conseguenze che sono effetto di
Fattori e di decisioni che non stanno
nella nostra realtà ma sono decisioni e
fattori appunto della globalizzazione e
in
particolare richiamare anche
l'attenzione su cui verità c'è molto
Silenzio intorno alla scelta che ha
fatto l'ONU
di di assumere il desent work sceglierlo
deciderlo e assumerlo il desent work
vuol dire il lavoro dignitoso dopo
magari lo illustro un po' meglio di
assumerlo addirittura tra gli obiettivi
dello sviluppo Millennium cioè il lavoro
è una scelta che ha fatto l'on fra gli
obiettivi dupo Millennium considerandolo
il lavoro il fattore determinante per la
dignità dell'uomo
naturalmente si potrebbe dire che
c'eravamo arrivati anche noi però è
importante che l'ONU abbia sancito
questa cosa e in particolare Io voglio
porre l'attenzione
sulla responsabilità che si devono
assumere le istituzioni pubbliche perché
il desent work diventi una formula
automatica che si applica in tutto il
mondo perché nonostante l'ONU l'abbia
assunto fin dal C per la verità ci sono
tantissimi stati dell'ONU che ovviamente
non rispettano il desent ork compreso
Stati Uniti compresa la Cina compreso il
Brasile Potrei
continuare ora sul come è cambiato il
lavoro per effetto della globalizzazione
i fattori sono tantissimi ovviamente a
me interessa sottolinearne uno perché la
globalizzazione mi pare che tutti per
tutti è acquisito che gli aspetti
negativi son determinati da elementi
speculativi con cui è gestita La
globalizzazione sia finanziari Ma io
dico anche non solo finanziari anche
imprenditoriali perché c'è anche
imprenditoria
speculativa Io voglio richiamare un
elemento che secondo me è stato decisivo
e che ormai si è affermato Purtroppo da
decenni mi riferisco alla
delocalizzazione delle attività
produttive la delocazione d attività
produttiva è proprio una scelta di
imprenditoria speculativa che
trasferisce le proprie attività da
quelle realtà dove il lavoro è più
dignitoso dove son più riconosciuti i
diritti contrattuali dove ci sono
retribuzioni di contratto collettivo e
così via e l'azienda è decentrata nei
paesi più poveri dove ovviamente il
lavoro ha una condizione economica
poverissima e dove per la verità
insediarsi in quella realtà non solo c'è
un problema di convenienza speculativa
sul costo del lavoro ma c'è una
convenienza Perché spesso in queste
realtà povere magari l'impatto
ambientale di quell'impianto non è tanto
preso in considerazione e anche tutti
gli aspetti legati alla sicurezza sul
lavoro sono più trascurabili e così via
ora c'è un bellissimo rapporto che è
quello dell'ilo del 2012 Lilo è
l'organizzazione internazionale del
Lavoro presso l'ONU è un'organizzazione
tripartita in cui fanno parte i governi
fanno parte i rappresentanti delle
aziende E anche dei Lavoratori ha fatto
un bellissimo rapporto proprio sulla
condizione del lavoro a sego della
globalizzazione che ovviamente non posso
qui illustrare perché è un bel volume
però richiamo due dati un paio di dati
importantissimi in base ai paesi che ha
preso in esame l'ilo è risultato che per
effetto proprio della globalizzazione di
questi fattori di decentramento di
localizzazione produttiva si è
verificato nelle realtà invece dove
erano più evoluti diciamo da un punto di
vista contrattuale dei diritti eccetera
si è verificata proprio l'azione del
dumping contrattuale cosiddetto Perché
Perché le stesse produzioni credo che
qualche qualche idea ce la possa dare ce
la possono dare i prodotti cinesi così
ci capiamo aiutiamo a capirci Che cosa
significa quando tu produci in una
realtà eccetera cosa termina Ha
determinato di fatto uno scontro
commerciale se così possiamo definirlo
dove In quella realtà più avanzata sono
stati e vengono messi regolarmente in
discussione i diritti di quei lavoratori
va bene al punto tale scrive il rapporto
dell'ilo che in quei paesi 2 terzi dei
Lavoratori non sono più non hanno più il
contratto collettivo di lavoro il
rapporto di lavoro non è più regolato da
un contratto collettivo ma da un
contratto
individuale su 30 dei paesi di tutti i
paesi su 30 diciamo i più avanzati di
questa indagine 30 di questi 30 26 i
lavoratori complessivamente hanno visto
perdere del
4,4% il loro
reddito
cioè l'effetto della delocalizzazione ha
prodotto non solo ovviamente la
delocalizzazione ci sono anche altri
fattori ha prodotto in quei paesi un
arretramento proprio delle condizioni di
quei lavoratori sull'altro versante è
vero che c'è qualche lavoratore in più
che può essere cresciuto qualche posto
di lavoro non sono migliorate le
condizioni contrattuali non è migliorato
il reddito di quei lavoratori È comunque
un lavoro altramente sfruttato anche qui
va fatta una
considerazione che sarebbe singolare
pensare che per far crescere il
dignitoso dove si sta peggio Bisogna
ridurlo un po' Dove si sta meglio
Sarebbe davvero un'idea un'idea dico
stravagante per capirci ma non è un'idea
purtroppo lontana dalla verità dalla
realtà A proposito ci aiuta molto anche
perché credo che il problema vero è che
nel mondo la ricchezza la torta della
ricchezza del mondo è divisa abbastanza
male non è divisa molto bene se così
possiamo dire l'ultimo rapporto oxfam
che è l'organizzazione la confederazione
che nel mondo si occupa delle
disuguaglianze ci dice che nel mondo l'1
per degli abitanti del mondo detiene il
50% della ricchezza mondiale ecco allora
io dico che se c'è il problema anzitutto
di far crescere il Descent work anche in
quelle ragioni che sono cominciamo a
partire dal fatto che la ricchezza Cioè
non esiste che nel mondo una persona
possa essere multimiliardaria cioè non
si comprendono più queste disuguaglianze
enormi contemporaneamente negli ultimi
4-5 anni I lavoratori del mondo la
popolazione mondiale dice il rapporto ha
visto diminuire il proprio reddito nel
90% della popolazione quindi ecco io
credo che da questo punto di vista
occorre Appunto perché richiamo questi
dati poi ce ne sarebbero anche altri
molto utili
quelli su come è arretrata e sta
arretrando anche il diritto dei
Lavoratori no come come ad esempio la
possibilità di associarsi ci sono 44
paesi dove la protesta E chi organizza
una protesta finisce in galera quando va
bene sparisce oppure muore cioè viene
ammazzato ci sono 88 paesi dove è
vietato lo sciopero e così via quindi vi
è un contesto davvero complicato da
questo punto di vista la cosa importante
Ecco che resta in ombra in questo
contesto è appunto Il desent che è una
scelta che ha fatto propria l'ONU fu
elaborata da linom ha fatta propria e
che dice delle cose fondamentali impegna
tutti gli stati il dentor dice Ah per
essere dignitoso un lavoro deve essere
duraturo e
stabile deve essere duraturo e stabile
deve avere una retribuzione economica
dignitosa cioè che consenta al
lavoratore di vivere con dignità la
propria
vita deve prevedere e consentire al
lavoratore la libertà di associarsi e di
farsi rappresentare perché in una logica
di diritto ovviamente lo capiamo tutti
il lavoratore nel contratto è il
soggetto debole non è il soggetto forte
nel momento in cui ha possibilità di
associarsi cresce la possibilità di
avere una condizione più favorevole da
un punto di vista contrattuale
retributivo e dei diritti infine il sent
Alco prevede ovviamente in modo molto
rigoroso le garanzie e le tutele Per
quanto riguarda la sicurezza sul lavoro
e quindi la la la protezione sociale se
se vengono meno uno di questi quattro
punti fondamentali non si può dire che
in quella realtà c'è il desent work E
quindi che c'è un lavoro dignitoso
Purtroppo su questo c'è una battaglia
mondiale gli stessi Stati Uniti ripeto
non applicano il desent work per non
andare molto lontano e paesi che erano
più vicini al desent work se ne stanno
man mano
allontanando oltre al desent work vi è
un altro come dire fattore che che sta
come
dire intervenendo ecco sulle condizioni
del Lavoro in modo positivo anche se mi
riferisco al salario minimo ora se ne
parla anche in Italia ma la Germania ha
fatto La legge ne ha parlato Bama quando
c'è stato il primo shoper mondiale di
tutti fast food Dove appunto propone il
salario minimo orario di $10 La Germania
ha approvato la legge di 8 € Scusatemi
50 Allora bene La Germania si è vista da
parte del Fondo Monetario Internazionale
a luglio nella relazione sul rapporto
dell'economia della Germania si è vista
da parte del fondo avanzare una
avvertimento il Fondo Monetario
Internazionale alla Germania gli ha
mandato una avvertimento scrivendogli
che il salario minimo avrà come effetto
controproducente come minimo la perdita
di 60.000 posti di lavoro come minimo
Quindi sconsigliando in sostanza
l'introduzione del salario minimo ma
perché perché qui veniamo anche al
dunque delle cose globali di come si
muovono e Come avvengono e tra l'altro
credo
che sia sempre più chiaro il Fondo
Monetario Internazionale sostiene che le
nazioni più sostenibili finanziariamente
sono quelle che hanno l'indice fiscale
migliore Cos'è l'indice fiscale migliore
l'indice fiscale migliore è quando per
un imprenditore il costo del lavoro Il
costo per tutto ciò che è l'elf quindi
le pensioni per quanto riguarda la
salute per quanto riguarda la sicurezza
il costo più
basso se io investo in una naazione dove
c'è il costo più
basso in sostanza su questo quello è
l'indicatore fiscale migliore quindi
quella è la nazione che finanziariamente
il Fondo Monetario Internazionale
sostiene va più
aiutata credo che purtroppo
drammaticamente Credo che questa linea
mondiale finanziaria del rigore
che voglio dire diversi stati e diverse
realtà hanno applicato l'Europa da anni
ormai a pressa l'austerità Tra l'altro
il Fondo Monetario Internazionale ha
corretto Già sette volte le sue Stime di
crescita del PIL le ha corrette al
ribasso Perché ogni volta si è sbagliata
cioè ancora non si prende atto che
questa politica tutta finanziare del
rigore finanziario non fa aumentare
l'occupazione non diminuisce il debito
pubblico i giovani restano precari in
tutto il
mondo allora in questo quadro il dentor
assume un valore strategico
straordinario Ecco la mia conferenza
serve proprio a fare in modo non solo
tra i presenti ovviamente ma mi auguro
anche in modo più ampio a sensibilizzare
l'importanza di questo e in particolare
voglio dire una cosa che in questo
scenario globalizzato la cosa che non è
più accettabile Dal mio punto di vista
È per non essere molto bellicoso diciamo
il silenzio delle
istituzioni cioè il ruolo delle
istituzione rispetto alla dinamica
speculativa che c'è nel mondo che sta
scaricando la CR
Il lavoro sta pagando le conseguenze
Allora io dico che gli
stati le istituzioni devono davvero
assumere l'impegno che è sancito
dall'onu del d e farlo proprio io dico
questo che gli stati intanto possono
fare hanno un'arma
fortissima Io non so quanti miliardi di
dollari siano la spesa pubblica nel
mondo intendendo spesa pubblica tutto
ciò che poi vi e innestato nell'economia
Penso agli appalti di opere pubbliche di
strade di scuole di qualsiasi
cosa penso ai servizi che vengono dati
pubblici dati in gestione ai privati non
è un problema però son comunque sempre
pagati con la finanza
pubblica penso a scuole penso penso
all'acqua penso a tante cose che il
pubblico comunque paga e sta
nell'economia in quel sistema Penso agli
acquisti di beni e servizi penso a tante
forme con cui viene sostenuta anche
l'imprenditoria Allora io credo che gli
stati devono davvero ragionare e sancire
un nuovo patto mondiale sul lavoro cioè
noi vediamo che gli stati Se si tratta
del terrorismo e bene fanno Poi lì ci
sarebbe da fare la riflessione Ma è un
altro argomento e ci allontaneremo dalla
discussione fanno bene voglio dire a qu
Ecco io dico che la stessa cosa deve
scattare per il lavoro perché il lavoro
Davvero è la dignità dell'uomo e se
davvero le condizioni del Lavoro stanno
arretrando sta diminuendo la dignità nel
mondo per il lavoro delle persone e
allora io dico che gli stati tutte le
istituzioni a tutti i livelli Devono
assumere il vincolo del desent per tutto
ciò che è legato e che dipende da spesa
pubblica qualunque cosa dipenda dalla
spesa pubblica quell'app palto quel
servizio Qualunque cosa sia lì è
obbligato quell' imprenditore a
rispettare il desent
work Naturalmente io stato sono anche
obbligato a pagare regolarmente le
fatture ecco per non per non per non
ingenerare un'idea
un'idea anti privato che non c'è e che
non ho non è questo il punto Il punto è
che gli stati Devono assumere questo non
è possibile Noi abbiamo esempi clamorosi
si costruisce il carcere anche qui e i
lavoratori restano senza pagati per mesi
quel carcere è pagato con i soldi
pubblici non me la posso prendere
nemmeno con l'impresa è il pubblico che
non paga
l'impresa Allora lo stato Non Può Essere
complice i miliardi di dollari che si
spendono ogni anno e che vanno in giro e
che producono PIL nel mondo non possono
favorire il lavoro indecente questo dico
Certo che non è semplice mi mi viene in
mente che qua sti troppo idealistico
però io lo vedo persino
semplicissimo perché questo non risolve
tutti i problemi però se ogni Stato
comincia dire che per ciò che gli
riguarda Quindi ogni nazione per ciò che
lo riguarda nella sua nazione fa
rispettare i principi del Descent work
io credo che nel mondo il lavoro può
cambiare proprio direzione perché oggi
la direzione del Lavoro nel mondo è
davvero una direzione che vede
pericolosamente arretrare i diritti e le
tutele di tutti i lavoratori non vede
crescere non vede proprio crescere la
dignità nel lavoro dei
dei Lavoratori quindi ecco io davvero
credo che la scommessa sul Descent work
dipenda molto da quanto gli stati le
istituzioni riescono a fare il patto per
il lavoro Il fatto per la dignità del
lavoro il patto per il desent che si
impegnano ad applicare in tutto ciò che
riguarda finanziamento pubblico a
qualsiasi titolo avvenga il
finanziamento pubblico Questo è un po'
l'argomento che io volevo trattare
l'argomento che
spero
favorisca la riflessione e mi auguro
anche che serva produrre qualche cosa
[Applauso]
Grazie